what's going on guys this is rob and we
are going to make a video explaining
konshu because i feel like that's just
one of the major moon night characters
that we really haven't explained yet
here on comics explain but here's the
thing to understand unlike mark spector
steve grant jake lockley whichever
personality you're referencing when
you're talking about moon knight konchu
doesn't really have a direct hand in the
various things that go on he does but he
doesn't more than more often than not he
operates behind the scenes the other
part of this is that khanshu is almost
comes across as much of a villain as he
does a hero depending on what the
circumstances are and regarding what
moon knight's doing who it is that's
writing the story so on and so forth so
i would say that much like most of the
gods that exist on earth or at least uh
originate from earth in marvel comics
he's neither good nor evil if anything
he's really just a dick it's just the
best way to look at it so in marvel
comics what you have and i use this term
loosely right because i'm not trying to
copy dc comics too much but what you
have is you have old gods and new gods
so the way this played out is that in
the beginning of things in essence you
essentially had just kind of like the
demiurge right and this was the idea
that the demiurge represented uh the
earth's biosphere right just existence
on earth and that what had happened is
that all these different gods had
basically been created by the demiurge
along with life so like catholic and all
those beings the way this played out
though is the old gods basically
descended into madness and chaos and
they all ended up just basically
attacking each other and they were all
vying for power and manipulating what
mortals existed at the time and so on
and so forth and so watching all this
unfold the sentience of mother earth
essentially gaia ended up going to the
demiurge and then asking to be
impregnated with the means by which to
destroy these various old gods and so
ultimately she was impregnated with a
tomb and so what ended up happening is a
tomb of course came into the world and
then essentially destroyed all the all
the old gods the only ones who didn't
die were the ones who fled right so like
cathode took off to his own dimension
other people took off to other
dimensions and then the earth was quote
unquote free and so following that a
tomb went into the sun and then
re-christened himself as amon raw and
then going forward actually had his own
offspring and really marvel has said
over the years that while you do have
people like honshu you've also got the
panther goddess bass who kanchu is a
brother to the panther goddess best of
course originating in egypt and then
eventually taking to africa specifically
in wakanda to lead the formation of the
panther tribe so where all the black
panthers come from all that kind of
stuff but following that the the history
was a little murky in the early days
involving kanchu all we really knew in
the old moon night stories was that
konchu was basically just an egyptian
god uh and that was it and that mark
specter was left for dead when he was a
mercenary and he was taken before the
statue and he agreed to be conscious
avatar on earth and then conquer
resurrected him and then mark spectre
went forward as moon knight eventually
developing the jake lockley steve grant
personas and essentially beginning to so
early starting the process of suffering
from disassociative identity disorder
right multiple personalities and so
because of this konchu is a perfect
example of one of these characters
that's introduced in the marvel comics
to serve a particular purpose and then
over the years just has all kinds of
things added to his history or ends up
taking on what is in effect a greater
role and so with the first volume of
moon knight focused heavily on the idea
that mark spector was just the avatar of
kanchu on earth a lot of this changed
when you got to moon knight vol 2 and
alan zalence and the reason why is
because at this point in time what was
basically told to us is that marvel was
trying to find a way to rework mark
spector's character because the reality
was as great as the old moon knight
stories were that there was a desire to
shift the character around because
interest was essentially dropping off
and so in volume two what they did is
they actually had mark spector walk away
from the role of moon knight right walk
away from being a vigilante in its
entirety what this did is it led to the
involvement of a character by the name
of anubis or really anubis the jackal
who was at one point in time an enemy of
konchu but being in possession of the
statue of konchu and with the statue of
kanchu at least at that time largely
serving as the means by which mark
specter could essentially harness the
power of khanshu it literally put
kanji's power in the hands of his
enemies and so what this did is it led
to mark spector essentially coming back
and becoming moon knight yet again
except this time what he was told is
that his powers would actually expand
they would become more prominent with
the phases of the moon now this was old
hat the power itself or the impact of
his powers basically expanding as you
know essentially on the cycles of the
moon this was a relatively new
introduction right when it was nighttime
and the moon was out mark spector was
stronger than he was when it was just a
regular day that was the nature of the
muni character the way he was originally
introduced expanding this and having his
powers fluctuate and wax and wane based
on the cycles of the moon that was a new
concept and so ultimately this of course
led him to going back to to becoming
moon knight and then running over the
course of volume two but much like we
had talked about in our video on moon
knight explained that konchu even in the
early stories right the original run of
moon knight a lot of what was really
given to us was that mark spector's role
as conscious avatar on earth was to
basically execute the whims and wants of
konchu and kanchi was always given to us
as this guy who was basically looking to
expand his power that where he initially
approached mark spector in kind of a a
benevolent way right i am here to help
you i am here to save you i can give you
back the life that you want and let you
continue on your path the reality here
is that kanchu saw mark spector as a
means by which he could expand his
influence and so while moon knight is by
no means the most significant threat to
anybody on earth the fact that he has
the backing of a god who is in truth
more malevolent than he is benevolent
although it does again kind of
interchange depending on the
circumstance it grants him a level of
understanding and power that you don't
readily see just because of the fact
that gods see everything and this really
came to bear in really in the mid 1980s
when you ended up seeing what was in
effect one of the weirdest stories that
was introduced regarding khanshu which
was actually in west coast avengers vol
2 issues 21 through 22. and it was
basically this idea that like kanchu
wanted to be an avenger
now the reality of this is that because
at this point in time mark spector was
already struggling with having multiple
personalities and that at the same time
you had him basically executing the
whims and wants of konchu albeit
unwillingly but doing it because he felt
he essentially owed that just because of
the fact that konchi had saved his life
it ultimately led to him butting heads
with the avengers and so what this led
to was basically him walking away the
reality of this on a publishing side is
that marvel wanted to put him on an
avengers team and see how people
responded they chose the worst team
but you know it was interesting to see
him play out or see his character kind
of evolved there right but it added a
little bit of a a little more dynamic to
conscious making him a little more human
in the sense that as opposed to being
some god that exists out there in the
heliopolitan celestial world right just
kind of like this ethereal place where
the egyptian gods reside ah that he in a
lot of ways had very human emotions very
human aspects and elements but again the
reality of conscious character is that
where he had mechanicians and he had
schemes and stuff like that in truth he
didn't become interesting until the
modern era right until i'd say maybe the
last 10 years of marvel comics that's
when he became the absolute most
intriguing more interesting than he'd
ever been before and we actually got
more information on him than we'd ever
had before and so if we're being honest
with ourselves a lot of this really
started with brian michael bendis and
depending on who you're talking to
bendis's 12-issue run which was referred
to as moon knight vol 6 uh that it was a
landmark moon night run now there are
some people who hate it just because you
have what's called bendis speak ryan
michael bendis was a writer who just
couldn't shut up so literally the pages
would just be filled with talking and it
would take forever to get through a
brian michael bendis story because they
were just constantly talking all the
time right just speech bubbles all over
the place but uh the reality and really
kind of looking at the nature of the
relationship between kanchu and and moon
knight in bendis's run is it basically
led to a breaking point that over the
course of his life or at least his time
as moon knight mark spector had
consistently engaged in these schemes
that were basically instructed by konchu
and that while some of them he disagreed
with and didn't follow through with
others he did but this in combination
with his his disassociative identity
disorder right having multiple
personalities led him to a place where
it even kind of brought back these early
day themes of schizophrenia right that
was the way it was kind of explained in
the old moon night stories is that mark
was schizophrenic eventually that was
changed and it was given to us as
disassociative identity disorder but
bendis built or at least kind of invoked
some of those schizophrenic themes by
asking questions and in fact jeff lemire
would also build on this later on which
we'll talk about but it was this idea
that mark spector didn't know if
anything he was experiencing was real
one we knew he had different
personalities jake lockley steve grant
who were at one point personas that moon
knight had created for himself in order
to access different aspects of the
criminal element or to operate as a
superhero in different uh you know more
effective ways but during bendis's run
it also brought in this idea of
schizophrenia insofar as is conscious
real is any of that stuff actually
happening and so all this basically
culminated in issue number 12 when he
essentially lost his mind and just quit
right just disappeared like that he was
just gone eventually he returned in moon
knight vol 7 with issues one through 17
this whole 17 issue run and it was cool
but one of the things that ended up
going on and one of the things that that
really began to hit home is when you got
to moon knight vol 8. now the truth is
that this run by jeff lemire it focused
more on moon knight kind of curing
himself of disassociative identity
disorder albeit something that wouldn't
necessarily last as it was the
relationship with with konchu but it was
a phenomenal run and the reason why is
that while it only lasted 14 issues it
is in my mind the definitive moon knight
run right the absolute greatest moon
knight run which i don't think we ever
finished and we probably should but what
ended up happening here is that a couple
of things took place one mark spectre
was sent to what appeared to be a mental
institution but what was really revealed
here is that whenever it came to konshu
and these avatars which again we'll talk
about his really kind of as his newer
history that's given to us um that the
way with this would play out is that in
effect konchu would wear down the uh the
avatars that he chose on earth and then
quote unquote at least according to how
jeff lemire explained it hollow them out
and what it would mean is they would
just be an empty vessel and what it
would do is it would allow konshu to
enter them as a vessel and then enter
the earthly plane with the attempt or
the desire to essentially conquer it
that so long as as you know the avatar
of kanchu had a working mind of their
own they could resist khanshu right they
could choose to do the things he asked
them to do or choose not to do the
things that he asked them to do and this
is really really important because this
fed into like the whole historical
relationship between khanshu and mark
spector insofar as the fact that moon
knight wouldn't always do as he was
instructed his conscience would get the
better of him the other part of this
which again focused more on the moon
knight element was him basically
reconciling his own personalities jake
lockley steve grant that kind of a thing
basically coming together and choosing
not to ignore him but instead to embrace
them and that in doing so they basically
destroyed this kind of illusion of of
conscious and in doing so kind of
spiritually freed themselves from the
influence of khanshu and so going
forward that standard that was set by
jeff lemire actually reigned supreme for
quite some time instead of konchu having
essentially control or such a huge
influence over mark spector mark could
choose or choose not to to be influenced
by conscious kanchu for the most part
maintained his connection with mark
because he still believed that over time
he could wear him down and then use him
as a vessel the funny thing is that what
jed mckay recently did was totally
change that up not in the sense of of
you know mark being a vessel but
actually changing the element of mark
spector being the fist of kanchu and
actually being the only one now there
were a couple things that were also
invoked here i mean there is a lot of a
lot of history here that is or is not
important depending on who you talk to
that that were that were kind of missing
out on like one of the things for
example is the sun king right basically
uh this guy patient 86 who essentially
was the son of amon roth and because
amon raw and kanchu had spent so much
time fighting each other uh that
basically sun king was like amon ra's
avatar on earth uh we can go into that
if you want to but it's widely
considered to be one of the least
interesting aspects of moon knight's
history right i mean moon knight fans
all over the place are just kind of like
it was a terrible run and i for the most
part have to agree it's not really
necessary um moon knight of course
overcomes the sun king and you get a
little bit of history involving consu
but the problem is the history that you
get is actually totally changed and
retconned in its entirety and the reason
why is because this goes into a handful
of different things the first thing it
does is it goes into what's called the
age of khanshu which actually took place
during uh jason aaron's run on the
avengers and then it goes into a story
called acts of evil and so one of the
things that's given to us or really the
the way this is explained to us kind of
patching packaging all of this into a
really nice neat little explanation is
that for koncho himself when it came to
the heliopolitan gods basically the gods
of egypt as far as human recollection is
concerned or documented evidence is
concerned worship of the heliopolitan
gods didn't occur until about 10 000
years ago so in effect when the first
human encountered bast and then a lot of
other you know several other gods were
worshipped at the same time the truth is
that konchu actually goes back much much
further he goes back to about a million
years ago if not before that the reason
being because during the age of konchu
and even during uh the the whole role or
at least kind of the one-shot origins of
the various avengers one of the things
that jason aaron introduced is you had
what were called the stone age avengers
basically odin and the phoenix force and
like star brand and different people
like that the first black panther from a
million years ago which never really
made a whole lot of sense didn't
understand why that was done but in
essence like conscious had been around
for an exceedingly long amount of time
in order to invoke a more human
attribute or more uh human traits to
khanshu what jason aaron did is he
introduced this idea that konchu
actually wanted to be a part of the
stone age avengers but was declined and
so what ended up happening is he
basically formed the first moon night
that served the purpose of basically
creating problems for the stone age
avengers and trying to implement or
trying to execute conscious plans and
motivations on earth now in terms of the
age of konshu itself this is actually
one of those few momentary agreements
between mark spector and konchu instead
of them just usually butting heads as
they always do that mark spector had
been struggling with these visions of
mephisto basically leading an army and
conquering the world but konchu had
experienced those exact same visions and
so what this did is it led konchu to
really come to this this realization he
could use these prophetic visions as a
means to essentially take over the earth
and so what he did is he told mark
spector the only way to stop this is for
you to steal the power of the avengers
and give those powers to me which mark
spectre did and as soon as that happened
konchu entered earth and he basically
took over manhattan he called it new
thieves and then started ruling from
there mark spector realizing that he had
essentially been duped stole the power
of the phoenix force or at least took
the power of the phoenix force and then
basically defeated konchu and konchu was
of course taken following that and
locked in the in the dungeons of asgard
but in terms of the acts of evil story
this was particularly interesting
because this is actually a kind of
initiative or storyline that marvel
launched but because they didn't want to
disrupt what was going on in the main
marvel continuity they actually put it
in a whole bunch of annuals now those
you guys who don't know what that means
in in comic books you have what are
called annuals which are usually
ancillary stories sometimes they're
important sometimes they're not it just
depends on what the writer wants to do
uh i mean you can have a story where a
writer is like moon knight issues one
two and three and then annual number one
and it all tells a complete story but
more often than not the annuals are just
throwaway stories they're completely and
totally unnecessary they may or may not
add anything to the story itself but you
don't really need to read them and so
because of the fact that they're just
extra stories that are out there marvel
basically had the entirety of annuals
for a whole bunch of different
characters completely reworked and that
where you saw characters facing off
against different villains they wouldn't
normally fight which made acts of evil
almost identical to the old acts of
vengeance story from back in the 80s
that what this did is it actually had
moon knight face off against against
kane the conqueror and so this of course
was kane the conqueror basically trying
to find some artifacts that would allow
him to maintain his mastery over time
without the need of technology and
because konshu is the god of vengeance
and time ultimately king the conqueror
ended up going after the artifacts of
kanchu what it did is it led to kanchu
himself pulling in different moon nights
from across the time stream all of whom
faced off against uh against kane the
conqueror and then of course king was
ultimately defeated but that's why i say
in the more modern era konchu has been
far more involved in the moon night
stories than he was previously that in
the old school moon night stories you
didn't know if konchu was actually real
he didn't really know if he was an
actual person who was there especially
because the early stories relied heavily
on the idea of potential schizophrenia
in mark spector and they leaned into
that right is concho real or is it a
figment of mark's inability to
distinguish between reality and fantasy
over time konchu has become really a
confirmed character to really exist his
motivations are questionable at best
sometimes he's a good guy sometimes he's
a bad guy it kind of depends but
ultimately he is there and mark spector
basically is the guy who just decides
when he wants to go into work
whether or not he's actually going to do
what kanchu tells him to so with that
being said guys if there are any stories
here that piqued your interest
particularly um and you really want to
kind of get into the nitty-gritty more
than what we were able to explain here
in this video let me know down in the
comments section right acts of evil and
the the moon knight versus kane the
conquerors story that was pretty cool um
and there's a few others here that are
particularly interesting on the age of
khanshu we cover that in jason aaron's
avengers run so you're welcome to to
watch that video we'll have a link to it
down in the description but uh yeah so
thanks for watching guys and i will
catch you all later
peace